and of course lefty daniel lynch will
make the start for kc well daniel lynch
if he's on his game he should be able to
tame the tigers if you if you're
locating and you got stuff like he does
and he puts it where he wants look he's
got a good chance
has the day off and that ball popped up
foul territory over goes hunter dozier
makes the catch daniel lynch has to like
that
pop up right side
with merrifield two out
[Applause]
fly ball down the right field line
solaire chasing it and is there to make
a fair ball catch right next to the foul
line
terry scuba is going to tow the rubber
18th time he's started for the tigers
this year he's faced the royals four
times in his career including two starts
one and three against the royals so he's
looking for a little revenge more
importantly he's looking to stop this
losing streak and get the guys back on
track it's getaway day in kansas city
and you always want a happy plane trip
that full wind-up and delivery oh get in
the gap
and it bounces up against the wall
merrifield stops at second base with a
lead off double
good start
gets a hittable pitch and doubles to
left center that brings up carlos
santana
knocks this one to right field
merrifield turns third now they're gonna
hold him
you've got two men on in the first
inning with nobody out and salvador
perez coming up
salvi with a shot to deep left that's
the way back is it back-to-back games
with three run home runs yes that was
tattered and battered over the hydration
station up in the next deck we don't see
balls hit up there very often enough
solaire up there
and now solaire ignites one to deep
center fedo to the wall and gone solaire
four to nothing
tigers royals offense is in fuego
herrera hitting 235 with seven home runs
41 driven in
fastball chopped toward third charging
dozier to scoop on a short hop high
throw tagged by santana to retire
cabrera
and a chopper toward merrifield behind
second he scoops and throws
candelaria is out
a soft liner to right center that drops
in and robbie grossman goes first to
third tigers got something brewing here
with two away in the second and castro
aggressive base running all the way to
second base
alberto
throws him out good job and lynch gets
out of trouble the royals take a four
nothing lead to the bottom of the second
hill hits it sharply so lair backing up
reaches up and at the last second was
able to pull it down
[Applause]
the ground ball santana nice play
two out they don't call it the hot
corner that's third base but man it gets
hot over there at first too here's the
o2 to scope and he'll chop it out
towards short cut off by dozier coming
over from third and his throw
is in time so daniel lynch
has three scoreless innings
solaire homer with a swing that the
royals have been waiting on all summer
oh get down
solaire is getting hot
i'll say
his fourth home run in the last five
games in the royals have a five nothing
lead
how about that the first strike that
lynch gets today is of the future hall
of famer miguel cabrera
dozier has to come in quickly but an
accurate throw
[Applause]
do2
swinging a miss what a good hard slider
90 down and in
hit another fastball for a home run soft
fly ball to center field hill drifts
toward right and makes the easy grab so
two quick outs
shot up the middle and that's right
where willy castro is little bobble easy
toss
that's two pitches really
wow look at that
slider that had grossman swinging over
the top and then staring back at the
tall lefty
to the right side merrifield
two outs
dozier
another one two three inning for young
daniel lynch
slices one to left
it's dropping and it drops in front of
dyson
two speedsters aboard
hit sharply merrifield to alberto
for the double play
so he's been basically pitching
comfortably and on his terms
all day the pitch
swing and a miss on a slider in the dirt
so with two on and nobody out the tigers
hang a zero on the board
well he's three for three and opposite
field hit a single to right
[Applause]
cabrera hits one deep to center field
taylor is back and there to make the
catch
here's the pitch to candelario and he
swings and it's a one hopper to short
alberto's got it and throws him out and
candelario is over three
here's the 1-2 grossman swings and
misses at a breaking ball down and in
and that's another 1-2-3 inning for
daniel lynch
who has thrown seven shutout innings
today
corners are in but he's swinging and he
knocks it to left center field and it's
going to drop for a hit
taylor's going to charge home here's the
throw cut off 6-0 kc
they have just two hits since ground
ball nice stop alberta to his left throw
to santana
[Applause]
another one that struck the center field
this time taylor will run it down two
outs
like that how about this eight shutout
innings for daniel lynch he pounds his
glove listen to the fact now giving him
a standing ovation what a job
here comes the one two
to center field there we go that's in
there
jonathan scope hustling home
without a throw and the tigers are on
the board thanks to the rbi single from
eric haas
struck him out that's the right pitch to
do it on
this could be two one
and
done
ball game daniel lynch first major
league win